good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the Democratic Party
wants to run the United States not just
the decaying urban centers and
gentrifying coastal pockets Williamsburg
Baltimore both Portland's no they want
to run the entire thing all 50 states
all 3,100 counties all 23 320 million
people possessives want complete control
of all of that very much including your
neighborhood that's their goal in the
coming election what will happen if they
achieve that goal we don't have to guess
instead we can assess a city they
already have complete control over and
have for a long time
San Francisco California now if there's
any place in the country you'd like to
run because it would be easy it would
have to be San Francisco the city is
stunningly beautiful it is a perfect
climate it's got solid infrastructure
there's a well-educated population but
more than anything it has a lot of money
San Francisco is one of the richest
places in the world with a never ending
torrent of tech cash how could you screw
that up and yet take a look at what the
left has done with San Francisco in some
San Francisco neighborhoods hold your
nose and watch your step you've seen
people lying on the streets seeing
people passed out on the street you've
seen people eat out of garbage cans
you've seen people shoot up adding to
the danger take a look junkies are just
dumping their used syringes into the
streets piles like this are commonplace
most of the needles are handed out by
the San Francisco Department of Public
Health to help reduce drug related
diseases but with no reliable way to get
them all back the city is spending
$750,000 to hire 10 people whose sole
job is to pick up the needles
some 8,000 every month looks like a slum
Bombay India doesn't look like that so
you'd think it would be affordable but
it's the opposite
average rent for an apartment in San
Francisco right now is about $4,000 the
city works only for the extremely rich
or the destitute the billionaires and
the vagrants normal people there's no
place for them want to raise a family in
the city good luck San Francisco now has
more daycare space for animal
that it does for babies it is literally
a city without a future its people can't
afford to reproduce and San Francisco
isn't alone the rest of California's
single party cities are following suit
the homeless population is in Los
Angeles for example is now bigger than
any city in the entire state of Vermont
it's filthy tent encampments are
incubating diseases we previously
associated with war-torn countries over
time squalor built up on the streets
with rats feasting on rotting food mixed
with sewage and used syringes but far
away from Skid Row through rats and
fleas typhus traveled through the
streets and the deputy city attorney who
works way up on the sixth floor at City
Hall got infected I felt like I was
going to die Greenwood says the building
has always had rats but what's changed
isn't what's in the building it's what's
around it the homeless population has
moved closer and closer they surround
the building so as folks walk to work
and back they're walking through rotting
food raw sewage typhus what country is
this who did this you know who did it
they do the same thing to Sacramento
that's the state capitol of California
homelessness there has gotten so out of
control that ordinary people can barely
live there I have to clean up the poop
and the pee off of my doorstep I have to
clean up the syringes I have to find off
people that push their way into my shop
that are homeless and on drugs because
you won't arrest them for drug offenses
I have to apologize to my clients so I
want to know what you're gonna do for us
the ones that are unhappy you want to
make a sustained sanctuary state you
want to make it comfortable for
everybody except for the people that
work hard and have tried their hardest
to get along in life and now we have to
change that because of your loss while
you've seen your million dollar home and
you don't have to look at what we have
to look at
there's hardworking people out there
that have to deal with this on a daily
basis it's a disaster
obviously and yet remarkably cities
around the country all of them run by
the Democratic Party are racing to copy
California Washington DC is now covered
with tents and filth drive around if you
don't believe it Seattle of course is -
Portland Oregon is well been almost
destroyed by it we've seen this before
for decades Americans fled cities to
escape from disorder in chaos and crime
New York got so desperate it elected a
Republican mayor and then finally in the
1990s the tide turned crime fell and
American cities became livable again
property values rose poor neighborhoods
got better everyone benefited and people
started moving back places that have
been shrinking for decades cities like
Washington and Philadelphia started
growing again it was a great success but
that progress is being reversed now
because on the Left law and order is now
regarded as a hateful relic of a less
progressive age among America's 20
largest cities San Francisco now has the
highest property crime levels in the
United States there are 70 car break-ins
every single day for the past four years
violent crime on the city's bart trains
has doubled that's enabled by rampant
fare evasion which city officials are
completely unwilling to stop across the
country America's most liberal cities
have mayors and DA's who explicitly side
with the criminals even against their
own citizens
we're not overstating this in Dallas
County Texas for example the district
attorney there John Kruse aute is
refusing to criminally prosecute thefts
of less than 750 dollars if he decides
this theft was of quote necessary items
okay
in Philadelphia meanwhile the top
prosecutor is a man called Larry crasner
he believes American law enforcement is
quote systematically racist so we
stopped providing law enforcement and
all in many places in that city
prosecutors no longer seek cash bail for
what they call low-level crimes that's
category that includes burglary not so
low-level if you're the target of it
shoplifters receive a simple summons to
court instead of a misdemeanor or felony
charge the results are not hard to
predict you know exactly what's going to
happen when you govern like this and in
fact it has happened in 2018
Philadelphia had its highest murder rate
in a decade
compared to staff you years ago murder
has dramatically surged in a bunch of
different cities with similar programs
Chicago Baltimore Washington and yet no
one in the left seems to notice any of
this or care in fact they seem to
approve apparently they'd like the rest
of the country to become just like San
Francisco do you want that